this week 48 hours is looking into the
mysterious deaths of two friends in Los
Angeles investigators say two young
women went out for a night of dancing in
2021 and were last seen at a warehouse
party later two masked men were seen
leaving them outside two different
hospitals CBS News correspondent
Jonathan Vigliotti on assignment for 48
hours shows us what happened that night
it started as a girls night out two
friends in their 20s captured on grainy
video dancing at a warehouse party in La
it ended in a murder investigation
your world was turned upside down
shattered John celier's wife Christy
Giles and her friend Hilda Marcela
cabrales had been dropped off at
different hospitals by two masked men in
a car without license plates the day
after the party both would die from a
toxic mix of drugs including cocaine and
Fentanyl and in Christie's case GHB
known as the date rape drug CBS News
consultant and former prosecutor Mary
fulginiti that is a drug that's usually
used by sexual predators that want to
take advantage of women Yan would learn
that hours before Christie was dumped at
the hospital her phone had pinged at an
unfamiliar address Jan posted it on
social media and responses came flooding
in there's somebody that lives at this
location that is a very unsavory person
it was the home of David Pierce
according to a police affidavit the
women met him at the warehouse and left
with him to go to another party somehow
they ended up at his apartment something
or someone stopped them in their tracks
because but could never got out and they
never left what
did the media multiple women came
forward to investigators all with
similar stories about their experiences
with peers he lures women back to his
apartment he provides them with a drink
and then they start to feel dizzy or
they black out and he sexually assaults
them David Pierce would ultimately be
charged with seven counts of sexual
assault involving seven different women
he was also charged with two counts of
murder and two felony drug counts for
allegedly providing lethal amounts of
fentanyl to Christian Hilda David Pierce
is awaiting trial and has pleaded not
guilty to all charges against him
Jonathan Vigliotti joins us now from San
Francisco Jonathan good morning so how
is the district attorney planning on
Prosecuting this case
yeah the prosecution plans to combine
the seven sexual assault charges we
mentioned with the murder and drug
charges in one trial at this point
Pierce has not been charged with
sexually assaulting Hilda and Christie
so the prosecution presumably will need
to establish a deadly pattern of
behavior ultimately at the heart of this
case at least for me is this 10 minute
window of time where these two young
women could have possibly left this
night alive but didn't
so what happened we explore that
question tomorrow night
Jonathan if he is found guilty on all of
those charges what type of sentence
could David Pierce be facing
yeah if found guilty and it is a long
road ahead Pierce could face 128 years
to life in prison
all right Jonathan Vigliotti for us
thank you very much Jonathan
you can see Jonathan's full report
Christy and Hilda's last dance on 48
hours tomorrow night at 10 9 Central
right here on CBS and on Paramount Plus